When a Muslim nitpicks on this and try
to answer them, see this again shows
people don't know how to evangelize
Muslims. Why?
A Muslim's not asking cuz he wants to
know the answer cuz even if you give him
a very
solid answer that's based on facts,
unless he believes every copyist
that copied
even the Quran, let alone the Bible,
must have been inspired by God to make
sure they produce flawless copies which
they know is not the case because the
extent manuscripts of the Quran have
thousands of variants which we never got
to. We didn't finish.
Then this is an argument not because he
wants to know the answer because he
knows humans will make mistakes in the
transmission when they're copying
from one, let's say, text to another
prior to the printing press. This is a
fact, but then how do we know the
Bible's preserved? The way the Bible's
preserved is that the Lord moved the
people to make mass copies in the
thousands of these individual books.
That's how we know that there is a
discrepancy cuz there's some copies that
will have 22:42, but the parallel has
22. So now when we assess that, all
right, that means these individual there
made a mistake. They misread the Hebrew.
So then we know what the original is.
It's 22.
But we wouldn't know this if we didn't
have a plethora of manuscripts where no
one individual
no one person had control of all the
manuscripts to then edit them and
corrupt them the way he wanted then send
them to the masses. That never happened.
Yeah. So the Bible from its inception
was being mass copied and spread over
the world. That's how God preserved all
the original wording of the original
autographs in the extent manuscripts
because your copy, let's say, in
California
and California's huge, let's say,
Turlock. Copy of John, John 1:18 says
only begotten son. But then there's
another copy in Turlock that
only begotten God. Then there's a copy
in LA it says so because the copies are
spread all over
>> Mhm.
no one person can collect them and
corrupt them. So that means even if you
corrupted your manuscript whether
intentionally or not you got a thousand
other copies of that same chapter that
read differently so we can spot the
differences and know what the original
is. Yeah. This just a fact.
>> Yeah. It's not just
transmission of the Bible. Any book
prior to the printing press
that has been hand copied
has variant readings.
The more copies, the more variants.
The less copies, the less variants. What
does that mean? So if I only have five
book copies of a particular book
because they're only five, they'll have
fewer variants among them. But what if I
have a thousand copies of that one book?
How many more variants do you think
we'll have?
Way more. Why? Because the more copies,
the more differences because you have
more copyists and copyists don't copy
the same way. Yeah.
So common sense tells you if I have a
thousand copies of a particular book
then I'm going to have a lot more
variants because no two copyists among
the thousand copy the same way.
Yeah.
But if I have fewer copies then the
variants
are not as much because I don't have as
many. Yeah. That's true of any book.
Not just the Bible. Ask any textual
critic of any work
of antiquity even of medieval period
prior to the printing
if you have more than one copy of a book
is there any book out there where if it
has more than one copy that has no
variants? They'll say no, they all have
variants. Wow.
And some of the copies are fragmentary
so we don't even Yeah. This is just the
facts. So when a Muslim brings it up,
he's not interested in the answer. He
wants to look you to lose faith. So then
why engage them? Because when you answer
one contradiction, he's going to bring
another and he's going to bring another.
He's not interested. So what I do is
there's two ways to cure
cure something. You either
cure the symptoms, but the problem
doesn't go away, right? Right. Or you
attack the problem, destroy the problem,
and the symptoms disappear. Right. So
what you're addressing is symptoms.
And you're going to keep addressing it.
I go to the root cause and I destroy the
root. I destroy the problem erase and
all the symptoms will go away. So then
what do I tell the Muslim when they
bring up the contradictions?
I said, "Well, if you're right, the
Bible's contradictory, then I can never
be a Muslim.
And you prove Muhammad is a liar. What
do you mean?
Because you're a Muslim, you believe
Muhammad.
You believe what Muhammad said.
Muhammad confirmed the books of the Jews
and Christians in the time
that he supposedly preached Islam. He
confirmed those books are the uncorrupt
preserved of God. But you're telling me
they're not cuz they have
contradictions. That means you know more
than Allah.
You know more than your God cuz your God
had Muhammad say those books
in the possession of the Christians
confirm they are true, they are from
God, they're authoritative, they're
preserved, and you need to use them to
judge the truth of the Quran. But you're
telling me Allah made a mistake or
Muhammad didn't know what he's talking
about. So I can never become a Muslim.
Woah. And that was it when what you're
referring to is it saying the Torah and
the Injil? Is it or is it
>> call the Islamic dilemma.
This Islamic dilemma has been the
nightmare of Muslims in fact the last
couple of months. Avery debated
a Muslim on Islamic dilemma, schooled
him, slaughtered him. Others have too.
You know, you have David Wood and
others.
This is what we call the Islamic
dilemma. Damned if you do, damned if you
don't.
I'll give you an example of how the
Islamic dilemma works as a Christian.
You believe in the New Testament from
cover to cover, right? Yep.
As a Christian, can you say the Old
Testament is full of lies and immorality
and genocide?
Well, you can because it's in there.
Like they described it's pretty
>> you can, that means that Jesus' view of
the Old Testament is wrong. He was
immoral.
So Jesus confirmed it. So then you're
not a Christian.
Jesus confirmed the Old Testament. Yeah,
he did. So you just said he confirmed
the immorality and genocide.
Well, that's different. Because he's
like he's like he's describing what's
going on. And he says he comes to
fulfill the law and the prophets. Yes,
and that that stuff did occur, right?
>> So it did occur. But when God tells
the Israelites to wipe out the
Canaanites, you're saying they made it
up and Jesus is going with it? No, I
don't say I don't think they made it up.
>> So then when God says wipe out the
Canaanites,
as a Christian, what's your position?
That God was being a just God and we
just have to trust that he was doing the
righteous thing.
>> saying it's genocide.
I'm saying it's evil. So how are you
going to respond to me?
I actually don't know how I would
respond.
>> Exactly. So you got to learn the basics
of your faith more than interested in
Islam.
See why I said when I began this, what
was my focus? To equip believers. Not so
much refuting Islam. So what I refute
Islam?
How does that then answer your
objections and doubts about what you
find in the Bible?
>> Right.
Okay, now.
My point in bringing this up is I'm
stuck with the Old Testament. Why?
Because Jesus told me I'm stuck with the
Old Testament.
>> Yeah. So I cannot be a faithful
Christian, faithful to Christ, and call
that genocide.
Because I'm saying that Jesus is
endorsing genocide.
>> Mhm.
Right. And that means he's a moral
monster. Is that what I want to say? I
can't say that.
>> yeah. All right. So to ask the question
again,
in light of Jesus confirming the Old
Testament,
>> Mhm.
do you have the option of questioning
its morality and condemning it and
rejecting it? No. Why not?
Because you're you're just trusting that
what God did was righteous, true, and
just. Why do I have to believe this Old
Testament's from God?
Because Jesus said he came not to
abolish the law but to fulfill.
>> That's the Christian dilemma.
I cannot reject the Old Testament
because Jesus forced me to accept it.
That's the Christian dilemma. So, you
and I are stuck now with the Old
Testament scratching our head how do we
make sense out of it? And by the way,
glory to Jesus Christ, God rewards
faith. If you take a step of faith and
say, "Look, God, I'm going to take you
at your word. This is your book. You are
perfectly holy and just and merciful and
compassionate and loving."
I don't know how to figure this out. I
don't know how to make sense out of it,
but I trust you and I know there's a
reason. Then he'll give you the answer.
Then it's going to make sense.
I mean, obviously I didn't It's not time
to do it.
There are answers. And then oh, okay.
Wow, okay, so I misunderstood this. Wow,
it shows how beautiful God is. Wow, it
shows his heart. But my point was
this is the Christian dilemma. I'm
stuck.
I got to believe the Old Testament.
Now, if Jesus never bound me to the Old
Testament, I would never read it or pick
it up a day in my life.
I won't waste my time with it.
But the point is you cannot reject the
Old Testament and be a faithful
Christian following the New Testament.
This is the Islamic dilemma. What Jesus
did to for you and me, bound us to the
Old Testament, Muhammad did to the
Muslims. He bound them to the Bible.
That's the Islamic dilemma. Learn it.
Muhammad said, "Jews and Christians,
here's the proof that I'm a prophet. I
confirm what you have to be from God and
you use them to judge that this Quran is
from God."
So, when a Muslim tells me the Bible's
corrupt, he's saying the Quran is lying.
The Quran told me it can't be corrupt
because the Bible will be the criterion
for the Jews and Christians to determine
the truth of the Quran.
So, if you tell me it's corrupt, but the
Quran tells me one of the proofs that
it's from God is that it agrees with my
scriptures. These are the words of God,
preserved, authoritative in the sense
that I am to judge by them to determine
the truth of Muhammad,
then either Muhammad is right and you're
wrong, the Bible's not corrupt, or if
he's wrong and you're right, then not
only are you telling me not to be a
Christian, you're telling me don't even
become a Muslim because he believes in
my Bible which you reject.
So anytime you bring up a contradiction,
I'm going to say wait, was Muhammad
wrong?
Why? You just told me these books that
Muhammad confirmed cuz these are the
only books they had
with the variant readings 22 and 42.
They had it. Yeah. Some copies read 22
42.
Did Muhammad not know about these
contradictions? If you say yes, he still
confirmed them,
then you're in trouble, baby. Mhm.
But if you're telling me he didn't know,
you're in trouble, baby. Mhm. Yeah.
Either way, you're in trouble. Yeah.
See, this is how you do it. So, what did
I do? I didn't deal with the symptom cuz
then I got to deal with this symptom,
that symptom, that. I went to the root
and I destroyed it. Nuked it. And this
is That's how you're supposed to do it.
And then And then with the Injil, that's
just the Gospel, right? Yeah, Injil
would be the Gospel given to Jesus but
the Quran assumes that it existed at the
time of Muhammad because it says to
judge by it.
Chapter 5, verse 47, and it says the
Gospel that's with them 7:157,
and even quotes a parable of Mark, Mark
4:27-28,
in chapter 48:29 of the Quran, and calls
that the Gospel.
There's a parable only found in Mark,
uttered by our Lord, Mark 4:20-29,
that is quoted in the Quran 48:29
saying, "And in the Gospel, this is
their likeness." So, it identifies this
parable as part of the Gospel of Jesus
Christ. Mark 4:27-28, you'll see it.
But if you want to read 26-29 for the
context.
>> I'll read it. Mark 26 through 29. The
kingdom of God is as if a man should
scatter seed on the ground. He sleeps
and rises night and day, and the seed
sprouts and grows. He knows not how. The
earth produces by itself first the
blade, then the ear, then the full grain
in the ear. But when the grain is ripe,
at once he puts in the sickle, because
the harvest is come. Okay, so you see
that parable is only found in Mark. Now,
if he opens up the Quran 48:29
if he goes to the Quran browser, finds
Quran browser
whatever you can find online, cuz
there's not anyone that's Sunnah, not
Sunnah. Find a Quran browser. If you go
Google, put Quran browser.
Yeah, open up whatever you can find.
It's right there. I think it came up the
first one.
Go to 48 Find chapter 48 of the Quran.
Oh, you found it already. Man, that was
fast. Shoot.
Go to 29. That was pretty good, man. You
impressed me.
All the way to 29. Now, you remember
what you just read? Yep.
All right, so when he gets to 29
read for me 28. Go down. Right there.
Read it for me. Muhammad is the
messenger of Allah, and those with him
are firm with the disbelievers and
compassionate with one another. You see
them bowing and prostrating in prayer,
seeking Allah's bounty and pleasure. The
sign of brightness can be seen on their
faces from the trace of prostrating in
prayer. This is their description in the
Torah, and their parable in the Gospels
is that of a seed that sprouts its tiny
branches, making it strong.
>> Did you not just read that in Mark
4:27-28?
Yeah, we did just read it.
>> You just read that in Mark 4:27-28,
right?
It sounds a little different.
It's in a translation. I should rather
remind me to hang myself. Okay, read it
again, brother. It says, "Their parable
in the Gospels is that of a seed that
sprouts its tiny branches, making it
strong. Then it comes to extending
firmly on its stem to the delight of the
planters." Re-read Mark 4:27-28 one more
time.
>> You're You're going over a translation
that you think it reads differently.
Read Mark 4:27-28.
>> He sleeps and rises night and day, and
the seed sprouts and grows. He knows not
how. The earth produces by itself, first
the blade, then the ear, then the full
grain in the ear.
And their parable in the Gospels is that
of a seed that sprouts and tiny branch.
Now, the word tiny, forget about a
branch. It's making it strong. Then it
comes to extending firmly on its stem to
the delight of the planters.
I know you're like, man, but it's got to
be word for word. Brother, this is
Arabic, that's a Greek. Yep.
The point is
this gospel contains this parable,
but it's quoting it in Arabic, you have
it in Greek, and on top of that you have
an English translation that's more of a
paraphrase than it's literal.
If I asked you,
do you have anything that sounds like
that in the gospel?
What would you tell me? I would say yes.
The only place is Mark 4:27-28. Now, I
see it has a number there, right after
the planners.
>> Mhm. Can he click on it?
That's it.
>> the planners is a number four?
Yeah, right there.
>> All right, let's see if it'll have a
footnote. It tells you Mark 4:26-28 at
the bottom, at the end. Yeah. Now, this
Muslim translation said what? In Matthew
13:3-9, Jesus spoke many things in
parables saying, "Behold, the sower went
out to sow.
Now, a seed fell on the ground good
soil, yielding a crop, some 100-fold,
some 60, some 30. He who has ears, let
him hear." Or the parable of the growing
seed in Mark 4:26-28.
20 Who told you where to find this
parable?
The Quran.
But the note is from whom?
Matthew and Mark.
>> No, the note the note that told you
where to find it. Is this a Christian
site? No, this is Muhammad. Muhammad.
>> Not Muhammad, that's the Quran. The
note, brother, the footnote. Muhammad
didn't write the footnote number four.
>> Right. Yeah, who did write that? The
translators.
The Muslims.
Whoa. So, what did the Muslim tell you?
Go look in the Bible. And you're going
to find it in Mark. Yeah.
Did you understand the connection? Yes.
I want to shave your head for Allah's
messenger.
I'm like, it's like it Okay,
it just told you
that at the time Muhammad, whatever
gospel there was,
it had this parable that is still found
in Mark 4.
So, they just told you that the crowd is
quoting Mark 4:27-28
for the larger context 26-29 as the
gospel that was their time Muhammad.
Cuz the gospel is there. It's saying,
"Look, you want to know their likeness?
You want to see the likeness of the
Muslims in the gospel? Well, here. The
gospel says this." And then the
translator is saying, "Here's where
you're going to find it. Mark 4." Here
it says 26-28.
26-29 but specifically 27-28.
Nonetheless.
So, the gospel of Jesus according to
Muhammad was there at the time of
Muhammad. They had it. They were to
judge by it. It was with them. So, then
you have to ask the Muslims,
historically, what is the gospel they
had?
This is now an issue of history. You got
to look at the history.
What is the historical data that tells
us what gospel the Christians reading at
the time of Muhammad?
Now, when you look at history, what
would the answer be? What did they have
at the time of Muhammad? They would have
the same gospel that we have.
>> This Islamic dilemma.
When Christians know how to master this
argument and present it correctly and
not get stumped and confused. Cuz a lot
of Christians don't even know how to
present it so they get stumped. Oh, he
stumped me. Well, because you didn't get
the point. Yeah. Once you learn this
argument, you learn how to use it,
there's no way for them
to get around it.
They're now they're going to ignore you
or dox you and threaten you because they
can't refute you because the Quran says
the Bible that the Jews and Christians
had
are the words of God, preserved by God,
to be used by Jews and Christians to
judge the truth of the Quran. Mhm. Well,
that's the problem my Muslims cuz my
Bible says that your Quran is not from
God. My Bible says Muhammad is an
antichrist. So, if I do what the Quran
tells me to do, I got to reject
Muhammad. Yeah. But if you tell me the
Bible's corrupt, I got to reject
Muhammad cuz he told me the Bible's not
corrupt. This is Islamic dilemma for us.
>> Wow.